♪♪♪
Tyra: BEING A TOP MODEL
AIN'T NO PICNIC.
SURE, THERE'S THE GLAMOUR,
BUT ON THE ROAD TO THE TOP,
THERE'S CUTTHROAT COMPETITION.
Tyra: CATFIGHTS...
Yoanna: I'M NOT FINISHED.
Ebony: YOU'RE ASKING
FOR MASSAGES
WHILE WE'RE CLEANING UP
INSTEAD OF CLEANING THE TUB
LIKE YOU SAID YOU WERE GONNA DO.
Tyra: BEAUTY...
AND... TEARS.
All: (sobbing)
Tyra: LAST SEASON
YOANNA WENT FROM BEING
A BABYSITTER...
Yoanna: (screams)
Tyra: TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW A NEW GROUP IS AUDITIONING.
THOUSANDS OF GIRLS APPLIED,
BUT ONLY ONE CAN BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
(sing-song voice) WE'RE BACK.
♪♪♪
Amanda: MY NAME'S AMANDA.
I JUST GOT IN FROM
HENDERSONVILLE, NORTH CAROLINA,
AND HOPEFULLY, I WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Man: ♪ COME ON... ♪
Toccara: MY EXPECTATIONS
FOR BEING HERE IN L.A.
IS DO MY BEST AND TO BE GREAT,
BECAUSE I AM GREAT.
I'M FABULOUS.
Cassie: I AM VERY OVERWHELMED,
VERY EXCITED,
A LITTLE STRESSED OUT,
A LITTLE NERVOUS,
BUT VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE.
Josie: MY TRAVEL COMPANION
IS BABY, AND I TAKE HIM
EVERYWHERE I TRAVEL.
Man: ♪ COME ON... ♪
Woman: WELCOME TO L.A.
IT'S GONNA BE A FUN WEEK.
Mary: I WAS KINDA
SIZING EVERYBODY UP.
IT COULD DEFINITELY BE
A TOUGH COMPETITION.
EVERYBODY'S GORGEOUS.
Natalie: I LIKE COMPETITION.
LIKE, I LOVE COMPETING
WITH PEOPLE.
Kimberly: THIS IS
SO EXCITING.
I MEAN, THERE ARE SO MANY GIRLS,
AND I'M LOOKING AROUND.
I'M LIKE, DAMN,
THESE ARE ALL MY COMPETITION.
OKAY.
Jay: WELCOME TO L.A.
I'M JAY MANUEL,
AND I'M THE ART DIRECTOR
OF ALL THE PHOTO SHOOTS.
Women: (cheering)
Jay: SO YOU'RE GONNA MEET
A PANEL OF JUDGES,
AND THEY'RE GONNA JUDGE YOU
NOT ONLY ON YOUR FACE,
YOUR BODY,
BUT YOUR TOTAL PACKAGE,
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
YOUR POTENTIAL TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND WE ARE GONNA HAVE A CUT
LATER ON IN THE WEEK.
AND THEN SOME OF YOU
ARE GONNA HAVE TO GO HOME,
UNFORTUNATELY.
Women: (groan)
Jay: SO TONIGHT
ENJOY THE FOOD,
ENJOY THE POOL PARTY,
GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER,
ENJOY EACH OTHER,
BECAUSE TOMORROW
THE REAL COMPETITION BEGINS.
Women: (cheering)
Leah: YOU KNOW, I WAS RAISED
IN OKLAHOMA, SO I WAS, LIKE,
AROUND COWS, LIKE, LITERALLY
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
MY GRANDPA BOUGHT ME ONE
FOR, LIKE, ONE OF MY BIRTHDAYS.
Woman: NO, YOU GOT A COW
FOR YOUR BIRTHDAY, SHUT UP.
Leah: IT WAS COOL.
Ann: LET'S GET HER DONE.
Eva: ANN AND I--THAT'S LIKE
MY SISTER FROM ANOTHER MOTHER.
SHE'S JUST WHITE, AND I'M BLACK.
SHE IS PERFECT.
Ann: PUT IT DOWN
BEFORE YOU DRINK IT.
IT'S BAD LUCK.
Ann: EVA--WE CLICK.
IT'S THE WEIRDEST THING.
Yaya: THE FIRST DINNER--
I WAS JUST REALLY NERVOUS.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANY
OF THE GIRLS YET.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
YOU KNOW, SO I'M JUST
EATING MY FOOD, AND THEN
ALL OF A SUDDEN, I HEAR...
Tyra: HELLO, GUYS.
Women: (screaming)
Tyra: GET UP! GET UP!
HOW YOU GUYS DOING?
Yaya: OH, MY GOD.
TYRA BANKS WALKS IN.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A HOLOGRAM.
LIKE, SHE DID NOT LOOK REAL.
Tyra: LOOK AT YOU GUYS
OVER THERE.
YOU GUYS EXCITED?
- Women: YEAH!
- Tyra: YEAH?
YOU GUYS READY TO BE STARS?
Women: YEAH!
- Tyra: YEAH? WHO'S GONNA WIN?
- Women: ME!
Nicole: IT WAS ONE
OF THOSE MOMENTS WHERE I FELT
LIKE I WAS LIVING IN A DREAM.
I SHOULD BE PINCHED.
YOU'LL NEVER HAVE
THAT FEELING AGAIN.
Tyra: AND THE REASON WHY
I WANTED TO DO THIS IS BECAUSE
I'M FROM L.A.
THIS IS MY TOWN.
THIS IS MY HOMETOWN.
Woman: ALL RIGHT, L.A.!
Tyra: L.A.
AND I WAS VERY LUCKY TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE WITHIN REACH
OF MODELING AGENCIES.
BUT I KNOW NOT EVERYBODY HAS
THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND IS NOT THAT LUCKY.
A LOT OF Y'ALL COME
FROM BLUEGRASS, OHIO,
AND I FELT LIKE I'VE BEEN
REALLY BLESSED, YOU KNOW.
I'VE HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS,
AND, YOU KNOW,
TIME TO PASS
THE TORCH.
Women: (cheering)
Tyra: WHEN IT COMES
TO TOP MODELS,
THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF STARS ANYMORE.
IF YOU NOTICE, JENNIFER LOPEZ
AND JENNIFER ANISTON
ON THE COVERS OF OUR MAGAZINES,
AND IT'S TIME TO BRING
THE SUPERMODEL BACK
TO THE COVERS OF MAGAZINES.
RIGHT?
BUT THERE WILL ONLY BE
ONE TRUE SUPERSTAR.
Mary: RIGHT HERE.
Tyra: THERE WILL ONLY BE
ONE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND SHE IS IN THIS ROOM
SOMEWHERE.
THIS IS GONNA BE A CRAZY WEEK,
OKAY?
WE'RE GONNA PUT YOU
THROUGH SO MANY TESTS
AND SO MANY QUESTIONS,
AND I'M GONNA BE FIRING
QUESTIONS AT YOU.
Woman: I'M READY, BABY!
Tyra: YOU READY?
ALL RIGHT! I'M READY, TOO.
ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
I'M OUTTA HERE.
Women: (cheering)
Woman: THIS IS
SO FREAKIN' AWESOME.
THIS IS A DOPE EXPERIENCE.
Norelle: TYRA BANKS.
TYRA BANKS WAS STANDING
RIGHT THERE.
TYRA'S THE REASON I'M HERE.
SHE SAW MY TAPE.
TYRA WANTS ME.
- Ann: LIKE, GORGEOUS.
- Eva: I LIKE THE COMPETITION.
I'M EXCITED, BUT I'M READY
FOR IT TO GET, LIKE,
REAL DOWN AND DIRTY.
Women: (screaming)
Ann: WE'RE ALL HAVING FUN.
LIKE, OKAY, WHAT, YOU DON'T
WANNA GET YOUR HAIR WET?
LIKE, I GOT IN.
MY MAKEUP WAS RUNNING
DOWN MY FACE.
I DON'T CARE.
EVERYONE HAS
THEIR BATHING SUIT ON.
WHY NOT GET IN THE WATER
INSTEAD OF STANDING
NEXT TO IT, YOU DUMB-ASSES?
- Women: (shouting)
Woman: LEAVE ME ALONE!
Amanda: SOME OF THE GIRLS
IN THE POOL WERE
VERY DISRESPECTFUL
TO THE OTHER GIRLS.
Ann: EVERYONE HATES US,
BUT WE THINK IT'S HYSTERICAL.
THEY'RE ALL INTIMIDATED OF US,
WHICH IS GOOD.
I DON'T CARE.
Mary: ARE YOU READY NOW?
Toccara: I AIN'T GETTING
IN THAT WATER.
Mary: THERE ARE TWO
PLUS-SIZED MODELS,
AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
OUR BOOB SIZES.
WE'RE LIKE, "OH,
WE'RE THE SAME BOOB SIZE!"
YOU GOT MORE RIGHT HERE.
MINE ARE JUST, LIKE, HERE.
Toccara: MINE ARE, LIKE,
EVERYWHERE.
YOU KNOW, MARY--I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT'S SHE'S REALLY PLUS-SIZE.
I THINK SHE'S, LIKE, 160.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR A REAL WOMAN
WITH SOMETHING JUICY,
THEN HERE I AM.
I'M 180 POUNDS,
AND I'M CARRYING IT WELL,
AND I'M LOVIN' IT.
YOU KNOW, SHE'S BEAUTIFUL
IN HER OWN RIGHT, AND I'M ME.
THEY SHOULD BE SCARED.
DON'T BE SCARED, AMERICA.
Brianna: I'M REALLY NERVOUS
ABOUT THE COMPETITION.
LIKE, I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF I'LL, LIKE, DO EVERYTHING
RIGHT OR I'LL MESS UP.
I DON'T KNOW.
Amanda: I'LL SEE
THE CITY OF DREAMS.
ELIJAH IS MY SON.
HE'S GONNA BE 2.
IT WILL BE STRESSFUL FOR ME
BEING AWAY FROM MY SON,
BUT IT'S FOR HIS FUTURE.
Tyra: J. ALEXANDER IS
A RUNWAY TRAINER,
DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE,
AND JAY MANUEL IS
A TOP MAKEUP ARTIST,
AND HE'S AN ART DIRECTOR, TOO.
AND I HAVE SOME NICKNAMES
FOR THEM.
JAY MANUEL IS "MR. JAY,"
AND J. ALEXANDER IS "MRS. J."
Ann: HI. I'M ANN.
I'M 21 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M A 6-TIME
ALL-AMERICAN ATHLETE,
FOUR TIMES FOR WATER POLO
AND TWICE FOR SWIMMING.
Tyra: SO HOW DO YOU GUYS
TREAD WATER SO LONG, ANN?
Ann: UH, WITH STRONG LEGS.
I GOT SOME MUSCLES HERE.
J.: HEY, YOUR LEGS LOOK
JUST AS GORGEOUS AS MINE,
BUT, UM...
Ann: MY MOM ALWAYS HAD ME
IN SPORTS, SO I BECAME, LIKE,
THIS TOUGH GIRL.
I ACTUALLY QUIT SWIMMING
BECAUSE I WAS LOSING.
I DON'T--I DON'T LIKE LOSING.
J.: CAN--BATHING SUIT?
BATHING SUIT, PLEASE.
Ann: WELL, I LOVE COMPETING,
AND I DON'T LOSE,
SO I WANNA GO TO NEW YORK.
EITHER WAY, IT'S BEEN
A GOOD EXPERIENCE.
NO, WHO AM I KIDDING? IT'S NOT.
IF I DON'T GET IN THE HOUSE,
I'M GONNA BE PISSED.
Cassie: HI.
I'M CASSIE. I'M 19 YEARS OLD.
I'M FROM OKLAHOMA,
AND I'M-A PUT IT RIGHT TO YA.
I'M GONNA WIN THIS THING.
I MIGHT LOOK LIKE
THE ALL-AMERICAN GIRL,
BUT I DON'T HAVE
THE ALL-AMERICAN JOB,
'CAUSE I'M A STRIPPER.
(record needle scratches)
J.: THAT'S AN ALL-AMERICAN
JOB TO ME.
Cassie: NO, IT IS NOT.
I USED TO BE A TRASHY STRIPPER,
I TRY TO KEEP IT CLASSY.
AND WHEN PEOPLE COME IN THERE,
THEY'RE LIKE,
"WHY DON'T YOU MODEL?"
AND THAT'S THE BEST FEELING
IN THE WORLD.
I'D STRIP BECAUSE
MY DAD WON'T HELP ME.
HE WON'T PAY FOR ANYTHING.
IT'S LIKE, "DAD, CAN YOU PLEASE
SEND ME JUST $20?"
HE SAYS,
"YOU CAN STARVE TO DEATH,"
AND THEN HUNG UP ON ME, AND SO
WE DON'T REALLY TALK ANYMORE.
Tyra: DOES YOUR FATHER--
HE DOESN'T KNOW THAT YOU STRIP.
- Cassie: NO.
- Tyra: NO.
Cassie: NO ONE KNOWS
THAT I STRIP.
I REFUSE TO DROP OUT OF COLLEGE.
I'M GONNA MAKE SOME MONEY,
I'M GONNA PAY FOR SCHOOL,
AND I'M GONNA PAY MY BILLS,
AND I'M GONNA IT BY MYSELF.
Tyra: AND BACK.
Jay: KINDA CONCERNED
WHETHER OR NOT SHE WOULD BE
LOOKIN' LIKE A STRIPPER
WHEN SHE WALKS.
I WAS SURPRISED,
SHE LOOKED MORE LIKE A MODEL.
Tyra: LIKE A LITTLE GIRL.
Jay: LIKE, I WAS LOOKING
AT HER EYES.
I SEE, LIKE, A DISNEY CHARACTER.
J.: I SEE A BRETT GIRL.
Julie: I THINK
I'M A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF WHAT AN INDIAN WOMAN IS--
PRIDE, OF BEAUTY
AND OF INTELLIGENCE.
MY WHOLE FAMILY WAS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD.
DON'T LET HER GO OUT THERE
TO THE MODELING WORLD."
BUT I TOLD THEM--I WAS LIKE,
"I'M REPRESENTING INDIAN WOMEN."
I WAS LIKE, "THEY DON'T HAVE
TO BE NURSES OR, LIKE, WORKING
IN A CONVENIENCE STORE."
Tyra: YOU DREAM OF
CHOREOGRAPHING
A BOLLYWOOD FILM DANCE?
- Julie: YEAH.
- Tyra: CAN YOU SHOW US SOME?
(Indian music playing)
Julie: I'M DEFINITELY
THE BLACK SHEEP
OF THE INDIAN COMMUNITY.
Magdalena: MY NAME IS
MAGDALENA MARIA,
AND I'M FROM WORCESTER,
MASSACHUSETTS,
AND I'M GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'M IN SCHOOL AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF MASSACHUSETTS.
I'M A JUNIOR IN
THE NURSING PROGRAM,
AND I'M GIVING THAT UP FOR THIS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I'M LIKE,
WELL, DAMN, THIS IS WHAT I'VE
ALWAYS, ALWAYS WANTED TO DO.
Tiffany: WHAT'S UP?
I JUST WANNA TELL YOU,
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
I KNOW I MAY SEEM
A LITTLE GHETTO.
I WOULD HAVE NEVER THOUGHT
I WOULD BE--
OH, GOD. YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
- Tyra: THANK YOU.
- Tiffany: OH, MY GOD.
J.: YEAH.
Tiffany: I TURNED
INTO THE DEVIL WHEN
I GOT INTO THE EIGHTH GRADE.
I GOT KICKED OUT
OF MY HIGH SCHOOL FOR FIGHTING.
MY GRANDMOTHER LIKES TO SAY
THAT THIS IS WHERE
I TURNED INTO SATAN, BUT, UM,
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
THIS IS WHERE I BECAME A WOMAN.
TO BE HONEST, I GOT
OUTTA CONTROL 'CAUSE MY FAMILY
WAS TRYING TO LOCK ME DOWN.
'CAUSE THEY SAW I WAS GOING
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
Tyra: WHY DO YOU WANNA BE
A MODEL?
Tiffany: EVERYBODY THINKS
I'M JUST... (scoffs) AND I AM,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I WANNA SHOW
PEOPLE THAT JUST BECAUSE
I'VE DONE ALL KINDA THINGS,
YOU KNOW, I CAN BE SOMEBODY.
I'M NOT JUST LIVING FOR MYSELF.
I HAVE MY FAMILY
TO THINK ABOUT.
I'VE DISAPPOINTED THEM
MY WHOLE LIFE, AND WHEN I TOLD
MY GRANDMOTHER THAT I WAS
COMING HERE, SHE WAS LIKE,
"HALLELUJAH. YOU KNOW,
MY PRAYERS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED."
Woman: I THINK THIS CONTEST
WILL HELP YOU USE
SOME OF THE BAD HABITS
THAT YOU ALREADY HAVE.
Tiffany: IF I WAS TO MOVE
INTO THE HOUSE IN NEW YORK,
IT WOULD BE GREAT.
YOU KNOW, I COULD SOFTEN UP
A LITTLE BIT, YOU KNOW?
I'M TIRED OF BEING TOUGH.
I DON'T WANNA FIGHT NO MORE.
Roxanne: EVERYONE'S LIKE,
"I JUST WANNA GO OUT.
WE WANNA START GETTIN'
OUR PARTY ON."
- Women: (shouting)
- (rock music playing)
Amanda: YOU KNOW,
WE'RE ALL DANCING,
HAVING A GOOD TIME.
(hip-hop music playing)
Toccara: AND IT WAS
THESE OTHER GIRLS SITTING ON,
LIKE, THE SIDE OF US,
AND THEY'RE JUST LOOKING,
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"WHO ARE THESE B's?
ARE THEY FAMOUS?
LIKE, WHO DO THEY THINK
THEY ARE?"
Woman: GET THAT SKANK ASS
OUTTA MY FACE.
Toccara: AND I'M LOOKING,
LIKE, "ARE YOU SERIOUS?"
Man: A DANCE OFF!
Tiffany: DANCE! DANCE!
Yaya: SO WE DECIDED IT WAS
GONNA BE A DANCE COMPETITION.
SO TIFFANY STARTS DANCIN'.
HOMEGIRL STARTS DANCIN'.
♪♪♪
Women: (screaming)
Tiffany: BITCH POURED BEER
ON MY WEAVE, SO I'M THINKIN',
"DON'T FIGHT. DO IT," YOU KNOW?
EVERYTHING WAS--
I HAD THE EVIL TWIN
AND THE GOOD ONE.
SO AS WE ALL KNOW,
THE EVIL ONE WON.
(glass shatters)
Yaya: SOON AS
I TURN AROUND...
(imitates glass shattering)
I HEAR GLASSES BREAKING.
OH, NO, SHE DID NOT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
All: (shouting)
Women: (shouting)
Kimberly: ALL YOU START HEARING
IS, LIKE, BOTTLES CRASHING.
YOU SEE BEER FLYING AROUND.
Toccara: IT WAS GLASS,
AND EVERYTHING JUST
GOING EVERYWHERE.
I'VE NEVER BEEN
IN A BAR FIGHT BEFORE,
AND THAT WAS THE BEST,
IT WAS FUN.
Tiffany: THAT STANK
POURED THE BEER ON MY WEAVE!
THIS NOT EVEN MY HAIR!
(siren wailing)
Woman: ALL RIGHT, BABY,
I KNOW YOU'RE MAD.
Tiffany: I'M COOL, 'CAUSE I
I DON'T GOT NOTHIN' TO SAY,
BUT I WANNA BEAT HER ASS.
ALL I KNOW IS VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL I SEE.
NOBODY EVER TAUGHT ME
NOT TO HANDLE MY PROBLEMS
WITHOUT FIGHTING.
Kimberly: YOUR HEAD
IS BLEEDING.
Tiffany: A LOT?
Magdalena: IT KINDA STUNK,
'CAUSE WE WERE LOOKING FORWARD
TO A NIGHT OUT.
I MEAN, SO THAT CUT THE PARTY
A LITTLE SHORT.
Sarah: DO YOU NOT THINK THAT
YOU DIDN'T PROVOKE HER?
Tiffany: DO YOU NOT THINK
THAT I SHOULDN'T HAVE THROWN
MY DRINK BACK AT HER IF SOMEONE
SPILLS SOMETHING ON YOU?
Sarah: I WAS RAISED IN A HOME
WHERE WE HAD DISCIPLINE,
AND I'M NOT
THAT BIG ON FIGHTING.
I'M NOT SAYING
DON'T FIGHT BACK--
Tiffany: OKAY,
SO HOW DID I PROVOKE HER?
YOU'RE JUST...
Sarah: ALL I SAW WAS YOU
BENDING OVER IN HER FACE.
Magdalena: BUT AT LEAST
SHE DIDN'T HIT HER!
AT LEAST SHE DIDN'T HIT HER!
Sarah: I'M SAYING IF SOMEBODY
IS CONFRONTING YOU,
YOU JUST BASICALLY
BLOW THEM OFF,
OR YOU BACK DOWN.
Tiffany: LIKE I SAID,
I'M NOT TRYING
TO DISRESPECT YOU,
BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU FROM, YOU KNOW?
Sarah: I JUST DON'T
CONDONE VIOLENCE.
Tiffany: OKAY, AND THAT'S GREAT,
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
I'M WITH MALCOLM, YOU KNOW?
LIKE THE BIBLE SAYS,
DO UNTO OTHERS
AS I'M-A DO UNTO YOU.
AND THAT'S JUST HOW IT GOES.
Women: (talking over each other)
Tiffany: I'M CHANGIN'.
I'M TRYING TO CHANGE
FOR THE BETTER.
MY GRANDMOTHER AND THEM
HELPED ME OUT A LOT,
AND, YOU KNOW,
I HURT THEM SO MUCH.
I'M GONNA CHANGE.
NO, I'M NOT ALL RIGHT.
OKAY? 'CAUSE I'M NOT GOING
BACK TO NO HOOD.
I CAN'T.
I'M NOT GOING BACK TO THAT HOOD.
I'M TIRED OF FIGHTIN',
I'M SICK OF FIGHTIN'.
I'VE BEEN FIGHTIN' FOREVER.
I'M SICK OF THIS...
Norelle: HELLO.
- Tyra: HOW ARE YOU?
- Norelle: I'M GOOD.
EVERY GIRL HERE IS SKINNY.
EVERY GIRL HERE IS TALL.
I'M THE ONLY ONE WITH BRACES.
I'M THE ONLY ONE WITH
BLING-BLING ON MY GRILL, OKAY?
Tyra: YOU SAID THAT YOU LIVED
THE LIFE OF, LIKE,
A REAL-LIFE CINDERELLA
WITH A BAD STEPMOM.
Norelle: OKAY, SO I WAS
LIVING WITH MY DAD,
MY STEPMONSTER.
I DIDN'T EVEN MEET MY REAL MOM
THAT I LIVE WITH NOW
UNTIL I WAS 13 IN 8th GRADE,
AND NOW OUR RELATIONSHIP
IS AWESOME.
Jay: DO YOU EVER PLAY MODEL,
LIKE AT HOME?
Norelle: YEAH.
IN MY ROOM I PLAY PARIS HILTON.
I PRETEND LIKE I'M PARIS HILTON.
I LOVE PARIS HILTON.
Tyra: COOL.
Jay: I SEE A LITTLE PARIS HILTON
IN THAT TURN, RIGHT?
Tyra: ♪ LA LA LA LA LA ♪♪
- HI. TELL US ABOUT YOU.
- Kelle: HELLO.
MY NAME IS KELLE.
I AM 19 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M FROM NEW YORK.
I GREW UP IN A PLACE
CALLED SEA GATE, WHICH IS, LIKE,
THE LAST GATED COMMUNITY
IN NEW YORK.
ALL MY FRIENDS--
THEY USED TO SAY,
"KELLE'S JUST A WHITE GIRL
WITH A REALLY GOOD TAN."
I'M USED TO BEING
THE ONLY BLACK GIRL,
WHICH IS FINE FOR ME.
J.: YOU KNOW WHAT
I LOVE ABOUT YOU?
Kelle: WHAT?
J.: THAT LITTLE
WHITE GIRL THING.
Kelle: LITTLE LIKE,
YOU KNOW?
WAIT TILL I GET A WEAVE
AND I'M LIKE, OH!
J.: YEAH.
YOU CAN TEACH ME SOMETHING
WITH THAT WALK.
I THINK SOME OF THESE GIRLS
INSTINCTIVELY HAVE OKAY WALKS.
IT'S THE TECHNICAL, THE POSING--
WHERE THEY PLACE THEIR EYES,
THEIR HEADS, THEIR HANDS
AND THEIR CLOTHES.
PEOPLE THINK
I'M A MIRACLE WORKER.
Tyra: WHOOP.
J.: SOMETIMES YOU CAN'T
CREATE MIRACLES.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
AND WALK BACK.
Mary: MY NAME IS MARY.
I'M 22, AND I'M FROM
PORTLAND, OREGON.
THE COMPETITION--SKINNY GIRLS
AND ONE BIG GIRL--
IT'S LIKE, WHAT IS
THE COMPETITION IN THAT?
I WISH THERE WAS THAT
ONE OTHER PLUS GIRL THERE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD BE GREAT?
IF THEY PICKED BOTH OF US,
'CAUSE THEN WE COULD GO AT IT.
Toccara: (squeals) HEY! HI!
I'M HERE! I'M HERE!
I'M TOCCARA, AND I'M BIG, BLACK,
BEAUTIFUL AND LOVIN' IT.
Jay: I THOUGHT THAT WAS
J. ALEXANDER
WALKING THROUGH THE DOOR.
J.: ALL RIGHT, MISS TOCCARA.
Toccara: I LOVE MY SKIN,
AND I'M WORKIN' IT.
I'M HITTIN' 200 IN THE BUTT.
WHAT?
I WANNA ENCOURAGE
FULL-FIGURED WOMEN
TO APPRECIATE THEIR BODY
AND TELL THEM THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL
AND THAT SKINNY WOMEN ARE EVIL.
NAH, I'M JUST PLAYING.
I KINDA HAD TO BE TOUGH
ALL MY LIFE.
MY WHOLE IMMEDIATE FAMILY
HAS BEEN INVOLVED
IN THIS CRAZY LIFE,
AND SO I HAD TO BE TOUGH,
AND I HAD TO BE THE MAMA.
I'M THE MAMA.
Tyra: WHOO! I HAD NO IDEA.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS SMALLER
THAN ME.
J.: BABY, WHEN SHE RELEASED
THOSE PUPPIES,
THEY WERE FULL-GROWN DOGS.
- Amy: HELLO.
- Jay: HI, AMY.
- Tyra: HI, AMY.
- Jay: HOW TALL ARE YOU,
EXACTLY?
Amy: 5'11 1/2".
- Jay: REALLY?
- Amy: YEAH.
Jay: AND HOW MUCH
DO YOU WEIGH?
Amy: 115 RIGHT NOW.
Jay: SO IT SAYS HERE THAT
YOU SAY YOU'RE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE ASSUME THAT
YOU HAVE AN EATING DISORDER
BECAUSE YOU'RE SO THIN.
Amy: I'M ON WEIGHT GAINERS
RIGHT NOW AND EVERYTHING,
BUT IT'S--IT'S GENETIC.
Tyra: SO WHEN YOU LOOK
IN THE MIRROR AND YOU'RE NUDE,
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Amy: I FEEL HEALTHY.
I FEEL GREAT, YOU KNOW?
IT DOESN'T AFFECT ME.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
FOR MONTHS, BUT IT'S JUST--
IT'S EASIER TO LOSE WEIGHT
THAN IT IS TO GAIN WEIGHT.
Tyra: I DO FEEL LIKE
YOU ARE TOO THIN.
OF COURSE, PEOPLE KNOW THAT
FASHION MODELS ARE SLENDER,
BUT YOUR BODY, I THINK,
DOES SEND A LITTLE NEGATIVE
IMAGE TO WOMEN.
Amy: I DO THOSE
3,000-CALORIE SHAKES
THREE TIMES A DAY.
Tyra: I DON'T EAT
THOSE SHAKES, GIRL.
I EAT BARBECUE RIBS
AND POTATO SALAD,
AND THAT'S
WHAT GAVE ME THIS ASS.
SO YOU NEED SOME FOOD.
Amy: IT WAS ALL REALLY GOOD
CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM.
Josie: HEY, Y'ALL.
THIS IS BABY.
HE JUST REALLY WANTED
TO MEET TYRA.
Brianna: I WANNA BE A MODEL
OR A DANCER, ACTUALLY.
Tyra: WHY DO YOU WANNA BE
A MODEL?
Woman: PEOPLE TELL ME
I'M BEAUTIFUL ON A DAILY BASIS.
Woman #2: I HAVE THE SPIRIT
AND THE SPUNK.
I DON'T HAVE BOOBS,
UNFORTUNATELY.
Woman: I'M USED TO BEING,
LIKE, THE PRETTIEST ONE
AT MY SCHOOL.
Woman #3: I'M A WHIP-ASS,
AWESOME, BITCHY DOMINATRIX,
AND I LIKE TO HAVE
A WILD, FUN TIME.
Woman #4: LOOK AT ME,
I'M YOUR CLASSY GIRL.
Woman #5: AND I MODEL
LIKE BUTTAH.
J.: ALL RIGHT.
Woman #2: THEY CALL ME
SUPERMODEL BARBIE 'CAUSE OF
THE WAY I TALK AND THE WAY
I PRESENT MYSELF.
Kimberly: I LOVE MY NOSE,
MY NOSE IS BIG AND BEAUTIFUL.
I CAN SMELL THINGS THAT PEOPLE
CANNOT SMELL.
Woman #2: I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST DON'T THINK
THIS IS THAT GREAT FOR ME.
I DON'T WANNA DO IT.
- J.: OOH.
- Woman #2: I'M WANNA GO HOME.
LIKE, I CAN'T TAKE THE
PRESSURE OF IT.
Tyra: BUT DON'T YOU THINK
ANY JOB INTERVIEW--
All: (laughing)
- Tyra: HI, LEAH.
- Leah: HI.
- Tyra: HOW ARE YOU?
- Leah: I'M GREAT.
MY NAME IS LEAH.
I'M 24, AND I WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN OKLAHOMA.
HOLY CRAP, I'M HERE.
I'M, LIKE, THIS FARM GIRL WITH--
YOU KNOW, I BUILD FENCES
WITH MY DAD ON TRACTORS.
Man: LEAH IS
THE GENUINE ARTICLE HERE.
WHAT YOU SEE IS WHAT YOU GET.
Leah: WELL,
I WAS BORN CATHOLIC.
MY WHOLE FAMILY'S CATHOLIC.
ONE BIG CATHOLIC HAPPY FAMILY.
Jay: WOULD YOU HAVE AN ISSUE,
UM, POSING WITH
THE "ILLUSION" OF NUDITY?
Leah: NO, NOT A PROBLEM
WHATSOEVER. NUDE ME UP.
- J.: NUDE YOU UP.
- Leah: (laughs)
Amanda: HELLO.
I'M HERE TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
BECAUSE WHATEVER THAT "IT" IS,
I GOT IT.
I'VE WANTED TO MODEL
SINCE I WAS 3 YEARS OLD.
Tyra: WHAT KIND OF PERSON
DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD BE
IN THE HOUSE?
Amanda: I'M THE MAMA.
YOU KNOW, I'VE GOT
A 2-YEAR-OLD SON.
HE'S GONNA BE 2 JUNE 7th.
ALL THE GIRLS HERE ALREADY KNOW,
LIKE, "YOU'RE A MAMA."
Jay: IF YOU BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
YOU'RE INSTANTLY WHISKED OFF
INTO, LIKE, A CRAZY SCHEDULE.
YOU CAN'T REALLY TAKE A CHILD
ALONG WITH YOU THROUGH THAT RIDE
IN THE BEGINNING STAGES.
Amanda: I WILL DEFINITELY
BE SAD, YOU KNOW?
LIKE, I'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
PICTURES EVERY MORNING OF HIM.
MY FIANCE HAS BEEN ENJOYING
THE TIME HE'S GETTING TO SPEND
WITH OUR SON BY HIMSELF.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
MY CHILD IS SO WONDERFUL.
HE WILL BLOSSOM.
IT'S LIKE A ROSE GROWING
THROUGH A CONCRETE CRACK.
IT WILL BENEFIT HIM
IN THE LONG RUN.
HE MIGHT MISS ME,
BUT IT'LL BE OKAY.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO
IS WORK SO HARD AT CONVEYING
AN ART WITH YOUR EYES.
I FEEL MY BEST FEATURE
IS MY EYES, BUT I'VE NOT TOLD
ANYBODY ABOUT MY PROBLEM
WITH THEM.
Tyra: AND JUST LOOK
ABOVE MY HEAD.
CHIN LITTLE BIT LOWER
AND LOOK ABOVE MY HEAD.
- J.: BEAUTIFUL EYES.
- Amanda: THANK YOU.
- Tyra: THANK YOU, AMANDA.
- Jay: THANK YOU.
Tyra: HER EYES
ARE BREATHTAKING.
Jay: SO BEAUTIFUL.
Eva: AMY--SHE WON'T SAY
SHE HAS A PROBLEM.
SHE'S LIKE, "NO, I'M ON
WEIGHT GAINERS."
NO, YOU'RE NOT.
THERE'S NO WAY IN HELL--
NO, YOU'RE NOT. WHY LIE?
Ann: I HONESTLY JUST DON'T
BELIEVE A WORD YOU SAY.
Ann: EVA'S JUST
REALLY OUTSPOKEN.
SHE HAS NO SHAME.
BUT IT'S LIKE A HEALTH THING
WITH HER, THAT GIRL.
LIKE, YOU NEED--LIKE,
YOU SHOULD BE IN THE HOSPITAL.
DID SHE DISAPPEAR?
Eva: I'M 111. THERE'S NO WAY
IN HELL SHE'S 115.
Mary: EVA--
SHE'S A FLAT-OUT BITCH,
AND I CAN'T STAND HER.
Woman: THEY'RE MAKING THEMSELVES
LOOK EXTREMELY BAD RIGHT NOW.
Eva: SHE HAS, LIKE--
HER BONES ARE POPPING OUT.
IT'S LIKE SHE'S GONNA BREAK.
LIKE, NO MAN WILL EVER
SLEEP WITH YOU.
YOU CAN NEVER BEAR KIDS.
IT'S LIKE, THAT'S NOT SEXY.
SHE COMES OUT OF THE ROOM.
LIKE, OH, PLEASE WEAR
A SWEATSHIRT.
DON'T DO THAT.
IT'S NOT FAIR TO OUR EYES.
Amy: I'VE BEEN LETTING IT
ROLL OFF MY BACK.
IT'S A COMPETITION.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR,
SO TALK ALL YOU WANT.
I KNOW THAT JAY MANUEL SAID
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CUT.
SO I'M JUST HOPIN' THAT
THEY PICK THE RIGHT ONE.
Women: (chattering)
Woman: I CAN'T HELP IT.
I WAS LAUGHING.
EVA, YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE SCHEMING OVER THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOIN'?
Yaya: WOW!
NICE TO SEE YOU GUYS.
MY NAME IS YAYA.
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE HERE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M REALLY HERE
IN FRONT OF YOU GUYS.
Tyra: I NOTICED, LIKE,
READING ABOUT YOU
THAT YOU'RE EXTREMELY EDUCATED,
AND I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR APPLICATION.
Yaya: I GO TO SCHOOL
AT BROWN UNIVERSITY.
IT'S A NICE, LITTLE
IVY LEAGUE SCHOOL.
I SPEAK PORTUGUESE FLUENTLY.
(speaking Portuguese)
I JUST STARTED LEARNING FRENCH.
(speaking French)
MY FATHER IS A PRIEST
IN THE YORUBA TRADITION.
IT'S ONE OF THESE ANCIENT
AFRICAN TRADITIONS,
AND I'M HERE TO REPRESENT
A BEAUTY THAT IS BLACK.
J.: SO WHAT PART
OF YOUR CANVAS NEEDS WORK?
Yaya: I'M OVER PUBERTY,
AND I STILL GET BREAKOUTS.
IT JUST COMES, AND I'M LIKE,
"YO," LOOKIN' IN THE MIRROR,
"WHAT'S GOIN' ON?"
J.: OKAY.
Tyra: WORK IT OUT.
NO CELLULITE.
Yaya: THANK YOU.
Jay: SHE'S VERY BEAUTIFUL,
BUT IS THAT SKIN THAT YOU COULD
PUT IN A BEAUTY CAMPAIGN?
Jennipher: HI, GUYS.
Tyra: HI.
Jennipher: HI.
MY NAME'S JENNIPHER.
I'M 22 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M FROM POCATELLO, IDAHO.
I WENT TO COLLEGE IN POCATELLO.
I WAS RAISED IN POCATELLO.
THIS IS POCATELLO STYLE.
WE'RE NOT THE CLASSIEST PEOPLE,
AND THAT'S WHY I NEED
TO GET OUTTA HERE,
'CAUSE CHECK THAT OUT.
Tyra: WHY DO YOU WANNA BE
A MODEL?
LET IT OUT. IT'S OKAY.
Jennipher: (voice breaking)
I JUST KINDA WANNA
GET OUT OF WHERE I AM,
AND I KNOW THAT I CAN'T
UNLESS I DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
IT'S NEVER GONNA GET ME
OUTTA THERE, 'CAUSE I'M NOT
GONNA BE SOME POCATELLO GIRL
THAT'S GONNA GET KNOCKED UP
AND STAY THERE AND...
SO I JUST WANNA DO THIS
TO SHOW EVERYBODY THAT I CAN.
Tyra: DO ONE...
(inhales deeply)
AND IT GETS ALL THE TEARS BACK.
Jennipher: I KNOW.
THAT'S NOT HOW I PLANNED IT.
Rachael: HELLO.
J.: OH, I'M LOVIN' THE LOOK,
HONEY.
I'M LOVING THE LOOK.
Rachael: I'M RACHAEL,
AND I'M 19.
I'M FROM HUNTSVILLE, ALABAMA,
AND NOW I'M MOVING IN NEW YORK.
AND I ORIGINALLY MOVED THERE
TO, UM, MODEL.
UM, I'VE BEEN
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE,
BUT I HAVEN'T BEEN GIVEN
THE CHANCE ON A, YOU KNOW,
BIG OPPORTUNITY.
I DO FEEL LIKE I HAVE A HEADS UP
ABOVE THE REST OF THE GIRLS
BECAUSE I HAVE EXPERIENCE.
Kristi: HI.
MY NAME IS KRISTI.
I'M 20 YEARS OLD, AND I THINK
MY MOST POWERFUL ASSET
IS MY BLOND HAIR.
Tyra: SO YOU DESCRIBE
YOURSELF AS A REPUBLICAN.
Kristi: WELL, I GO TO SCHOOL
IN NEW YORK, AND IT'S LIKE
I'M THE ONLY REPUBLICAN
IN THE STATE.
MY PROM DRESS SENIOR YEAR
WAS AN AMERICAN FLAG.
SO I WAS BEING PATRIOTIC,
I GUESS.
TA-DA!
("Yankee Doodle Dandy" playing)
Kristi: YEAH. HERE IT IS.
J.: I WOULD HAVE DONE
A RED SPARKLE SHOE.
Nicole: THIS COMPETITION
REALLY WAS, LIKE,
"AH, I COULD DO THAT.
THAT'S SO GLAMOROUS,
THAT'S SO FABULOUS."
Tyra: YOU SAY THAT YOU HAVE
TO WATCH YOUR DRINKING
'CAUSE WHEN YOU DRINK
YOU LOVE EVERYONE?
Nicole: I DO,
I GET VERY FRIENDLY.
I'M VERY TRUSTING.
I'M VERY OPEN, AND I LOVE YOU.
Jay: SO IS THAT
MEN AND WOMEN?
Nicole: UM, YEAH,
I DON'T DISCRIMINATE, REALLY.
J.: SO YOU'RE
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY EMPLOYER.
Nicole: YEAH, DEFINITELY.
I FEEL LIKE SEXUALITY
SHOULDN'T BE LIMITED.
J.: OH.
Nargis: HEY,
MY NAME'S NARGIS.
I'M 24 YEARS OLD,
AND I AM READY TO ROCK 'N' ROLL
AND YOU--LET YOU GUYS MAKE ME
AMERICA'S NE--NEXT TOP MODEL,
IF I CAN SPEAK RIGHT!
Tyra: WHEN YOU PRACTICE IT
AND IT'S NOT NATURAL,
YOU MESS UP.
Nargis: I KNOW,
BUT I'M SO NERVOUS.
WHEN I TRIED OUT FOR
LAST SEASON OF "TOP MODEL,"
I GOT INTO THE SEMI-FINALISTS,
AND ITS WAS VERY, VERY EXCITING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT I'M GETTING
A SECOND CHANCE.
- Tyra: I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED.
- Nargis: UH-OH.
Tyra: YOU SAID THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE A FAVORITE MODEL
OR A LEAST FAVORITE MODEL.
Nargis: NO, I DON'T.
Tyra: SO WHY DO YOU WANNA
BE A MODEL?
WHAT INSPIRES YOU?
Nargis: TO ME, I LOOK AT IT
AS A JOB, AND THAT'S IT.
Jay: SO THEN WHY NOT DO
SOMETHING ELSE?
LIKE GO--YEAH, EXACTLY.
Nargis: I DON'T KNOW HOW TO,
LIKE, REDEEM MYSELF.
UM...
I GET REALLY NERVOUS.
SOMETIMES I LOSE
MY TRAIN OF THOUGHT.
Jay: I LIKE HER BODY.
I MEAN...
Tyra: I LOVED HER BODY.
J.: WHAT DO I LOOK FOR
WHEN THESE GIRLS
WALK THROUGH THE DOOR?
GOOD D.N.A.
I LOOK FOR A GIRL THAT CAN
COME IN AND JUST DELIVER.
- Tyra: WORK IT OUT.
- Jay: I LOVE IT.
Tyra: HOW DO YOU
COMPARE YOURSELF
TO THE OTHER GIRLS OUT THERE?
Eva: I DON'T COMPARE MYSELF
TO OTHER GIRLS.
I'M EVA. I'M NO COMPARISON
TO ANYONE ELSE.
Tyra: ABOUT 80% OF THE GIRLS
THAT COME IN HERE
HAVE SOMETHING NEGATIVE
TO SAY ABOUT YOU.
Kelle: EVA--
SHE'S SAYING THIS ABOUT ME
AND SAYING THAT ABOUT ME.
- Nicole: EVA...
- Mary: SHE WAS ALWAYS
MEAN TO ME.
Cassie: EVA...
Woman: EXCESSIVELY ABRASIVE
AND HOSTILE.
- Woman #2: EVA...
- Norelle: SHE'S OUT OF CONTROL.
Julie: DIVA EVA.
Eva: A LOT OF THESE WOMEN
ARE ULTRA SENSITIVE.
NOW HOW ARE YOU GONNA WANNA
BECOME A MODEL
AND TAKE CRITICISM--
Tyra: BUT DO YOU FEEL
THERE'S A NEED TO BE NASTY?
DO YOU FEEL THERE'S A NEED
TO BE NEGATIVE?
Eva: I'M NOT NASTY
AND I'M NOT NEGATIVE.
WELL, I VOCALLY SAID
AMY LOOKS NASTY.
THAT WAS VERY MEAN,
BUT AMY LOOKS NASTY.
Tyra: THE FIRST TWO SEASONS
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WE HAD GIRLS THAT WERE BITCHES.
THEY DIDN'T WALK IN AS BITCHES,
BUT THEY GET TO THE HOUSE,
AND THEY'RE CONSIDERED A BITCH.
I DON'T WANNA CAST
ANOTHER BLACK BITCH.
Eva: INSTEAD OF ME BEING FAKE
AND ACTING LIKE I LIKE YOU
OR ACTING ONE WAY OR THE OTHER,
I'M GONNA ACT EXACTLY
HOW I FEEL, AND I DON'T WANNA
HURT ANYONE'S FEELINGS,
BUT I THINK IT HURTS--
Tyra: I THINK YOU DO.
YOU DO WANNA HURT
PEOPLE'S FEELINGS.
Eva: I DON'T.
Tyra: YOU'RE A SMART GIRL, EVA,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU KNOW HOW TO HURT PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN HURT BEFORE.
Eva: I MEAN,
BUT THAT'S EVERYONE.
EVERYONE HAS GONE THROUGH
THINGS IN THEIR LIVES.
YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN INDEPENDENT
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
I CAN RUN TO AND SAY THIS--
IF I GET HURT, I RUN TO MYSELF.
I CAN'T RUN TO MOM.
I CAN'T RUN TO DAD.
I LIVE BY MYSELF.
I'M JUST NOT A SENSITIVE PERSON,
AND I TRY NOT TO BE.
Tyra: BUT YOU ARE
A SENSITIVE PERSON
BECAUSE YOU'RE TEARING UP
RIGHT NOW, AND THAT IS
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL PART OF YOU
I'VE SEEN.
WHO IN YOUR LIFE SAID
NEGATIVE THINGS TO YOU?
THAT YOU WEREN'T GOOD ENOUGH,
THAT...
WHO? GIVE ME SOME
OF THE STRONGEST PEOPLE.
Eva: I MEAN, MY PARENTS,
MY FATHER, MY BROTHERS,
CLASSMATES, EVERYONE.
Tyra: JUST REMEMBER
HOW IT FELT WHEN YOUR DADDY
SAID HORRIBLE THINGS TO YOU.
YOU DON'T WANNA ANYBODY ELSE
TO FEEL LIKE THAT.
YOU WANNA COME GIVE ME A HUG?
Eva: EXCUSE ME.
UM, I GUESS THE WHOLE REASON
I'M STANDING HERE
AND I WANNA SAY SOMETHING
IS BECAUSE I KNOW I HAVE BEEN
RUDE TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I'VE SAID HURTFUL THINGS,
AND SO I'M APOLOGIZING.
I'M SORRY FOR ANYTHING
THAT I'VE SAID
TO HURT YOUR FEELINGS,
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT YOU
TO LEAVE HERE WITH
A NEGATIVE IMPRESSION OF ME.
I DO WANNA APOLOGIZE
TO EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
BECAUSE YOU ALL ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY BEAUTIFUL.
Woman: WHOO!
Kimberly: THAT'S A PERFECT--
I GIVE HER AN APPLAUSE.
SHE'S SMART, SHE'S INTELLIGENT,
AND SHE GOT GAME.
Amy: MAYBE IT WAS HEARTFELT,
MAYBE IT WASN'T, BUT IT'S LIKE
I FELT LIKE IT WAS
TOTALLY PROVOKED BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW PEOPLE
ARE GETTING CUT,
SO SHE WANTS TO MAKE
AS "GOOD" OF AN IMPRESSION
AS POSSIBLE WHEN SHE SHOULD
HAVE DONE THAT FROM DAY ONE.
Jay: HI, Y'ALL.
Women: (cheering)
Jay: I GUESS YOU GUYS KNOW
WHAT I'M HERE TO TELL YOU.
WE'VE GOTTA MAKE A CUT,
SO TOMORROW MORNING
THERE'LL BE A LIST POSTED
OF THE GIRLS WHO ARE GONNA STAY
AND MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
NOW THOSE WHO STAY ARE GONNA DO
A LITTLE PHOTO SHOOT WITH ME,
AND THOSE WHO GO, UNFORTUNATELY,
HAVE TO PACK THEIR BAGS,
AND THEY GOTTA GO HOME.
GOOD LUCK.
BUT WE GOT A DIFFICULT DECISION
AHEAD OF US, OKAY?
Mary: THERE'S GONNA BE
AN ELIMINATION THIS MORNING.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
Nargis: IT WAS REALLY CRAZY
WAKING UP THIS MORNING.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE REALLY ANXIOUS,
WANTING TO KNOW, YOU KNOW,
WHO'S GONNA GET CUT.
Eva: WHEN I FIRST CAME,
I WAS BEYOND CONFIDENT,
BUT AFTER SPEAKING TO THE PANEL,
I DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
I DESERVED IT, BEING RUDE
AND BITCHY TO THE GIRLS.
(sighs) I JUST NEED TO BREATHE.
Michelle: I HAVE TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT THE PANEL
WAS REALLY IMPRESSED,
AND THEY HAD A HARD TIME,
BUT THROUGH
CAREFUL DELIBERATION,
THEY HAVE CHOSEN ONLY
TO ADVANCE 20 TO THE NEXT ROUND.
Tiffany: A LOT OF GIRLS
CAN SAY,
"OH, IF I DON'T MAKE IT HERE,
I CAN GO BACK TO DOING THIS."
WELL, I DON'T WANNA GO BACK,
I'M NOT GOING BACK.
Cassie: IF I DON'T MAKE IT,
I WILL HAVE TO GO BACK
TO STRIPPING.
I DON'T WANT TO,
BUT I HAVE TO PAY MY BILLS.
Toccara: MY WHOLE BODY
FEELS WEAK.
I'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS MOMENT ALL MY LIFE.
Michelle: YOU GUYS,
THE NAMES ON THIS LIST
ARE THE NEXT GIRLS THAT ARE
ON THEIR WAY
TO HOPEFULLY BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
GOOD LUCK.
Women: (cheering)
(screaming)
Eva: IT'S LIKE
IT'S OVERWHELMING JOY.
I DEFINITELY THINK
I CAN WIN THIS.
Amanda: WORDS CANNOT DESCRIBE
THE JOY THAT I FEEL RIGHT NOW.
Nargis: GOING THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AGAIN
ACTUALLY WAS MORE EXCITING,
BUT I KNOW HOW ALL THE GIRLS
THAT DID NOT MAKE IT--
I KNOW HOW THEY FEEL.
Women: (screaming)
Woman: I STARTED CRYING
BEFORE I WENT UP THERE BECAUSE
IF YOU'RE MEANT TO GO,
YOU'RE MEANT TO GO.
Eva: EXACTLY.
Woman: AND I'M NOT MEANT
TO GO.
Amy: THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN
A BIG JUMP FOR ME,
BUT THEY CHOSE WHO THEY CHOSE
AND I HOPE WHOEVER WINS
DESERVES IT.
Tiffany: I'M COOL.
YOU KNOW, I'M TOUGH.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M CRYING
RIGHT NOW.
YEAH.
SOME PEOPLE NEVER CHANGE.
I MEAN, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A BIG CHANGE FROM HUSTLIN'
TO BEING GLAMOUR GIRL, ANYWAY.
I JUST HATE TO GO BACK
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE GONNA LOOK
AT ME AND SAY, "I TOLD YOU SO."
IT'S COOL, YOU KNOW,
I'M USED TO FAILIN'.
SOMEBODY GOTTA FAIL, RIGHT?
Mary: THEY ELIMINATED
14 PEOPLE.
I WAS HAPPY TO SEE
THAT BOTH PLUS-SIZE GIRLS
WERE STILL HERE,
BUT THERE'S STILL GONNA BE
ANOTHER CUT.
MY ANXIETY'S NOT OVER AT ALL.
Amanda: I'M WORKING SO HARD
TO SEEM NORMAL.
I WOULD FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
IF THE GIRLS KNEW
ABOUT MY PROBLEM.
Michelle: YOU GUYS, HANG ON.
SHH, SHH.
Amanda: FIRST OF ALL,
I'M SORRY FOR THOSE
WHO HAVEN'T MADE IT.
I'M SO HAPPY FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE.
I HAVEN'T BEEN COMPLETELY
HONEST WITH EVERYBODY.
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT I DIDN'T
WANT TO LET Y'ALL KNOW.
I DIDN'T WANT IT
TO AFFECT EVERYBODY.
I'M LEGALLY BLIND.
Women: (gasp)
Amanda: AND I'M GONNA BE
ABOUT 30 WHEN I GO
COMPLETELY BLIND.
Amanda:
I HAVEN'T BEEN COMPLETELY
HONEST WITH EVERYBODY.
I'M LEGALLY BLIND.
Women: (gasp)
AND I'M GONNA BE ABOUT 30
WHEN I GO COMPLETELY BLIND.
IT'S A DISEASE CALLED
RETINITIS PIGMENTOSA.
IT'S A DEGENERATIVE
PERIPHERAL DISEASE.
IT'S LIKE I CAN'T SEE
RIGHT HERE.
BUT I CAN SEE RIGHT HERE.
AND I JUST WANTED Y'ALL TO KNOW
I WILL ALWAYS SEE YOUR FACE.
PLEASE DON'T CRY.
I'VE HAD TEN YEARS
TO GET USED TO THIS.
I'VE SEEN MY SON'S SMILE,
AND THAT'S ALL I EVER WANTED.
IF WE'RE ALL PLAYING
THE SAME GAME
BUT I'M ON A DIFFERENT FIELD,
I'M NOT GONNA LET ANYTHING
GET IN MY WAY,
EVEN WHAT SETS ME BACK
A COUPLE OF STEPS.
THAT MEANS I'VE JUST GOTTA TAKE
BIGGER, STRONGER STEPS.
Women: (cheering)
Jay: SOMEBODY HERE
IS GONNA WIN THE COMPETITION.
Women: (cheering)
Jay: SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS WE'LL DO
A LITTLE PHOTO SHOOT.
IT'S GONNA BE VERY, VERY SIMPLE.
I'M GONNA USE
MY LITTLE DIGITAL CAMERA.
THERE'S GONNA BE NO HAIR
AND MAKEUP AND CLOTHES.
IT'S JUST GONNA BE ALL ABOUT
THE DIRECTION THAT YOU GET
FROM ME AND CAN YOU REALLY TAKE
THAT DIRECTION?
♪♪♪
- Ann: TALK TO ME HERE.
- Jay: OKAY.
THINK OF RIGHT HERE--
PRETEND LIKE THERE'S A LITTLE
THREAD PULLING YOU LONG.
COOL.
TURN.
YOU WERE LIKE THIS.
YOUR SHOULDER WAS RAISED KINDA.
Nargis: THIS IS KINDA HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT.
Jay: GIVE ME A LITTLE MORE
SEXY THIS TIME.
I WOULDN'T CALL IT SEXY.
I'D CALL IT, LIKE, LITTLE GIRL.
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
GIVE ME STRONG.
DON'T BE AFRAID OF THE CAMERA.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
WE GOT 20 GIRLS, AND WE HAVE TO
NARROW IT DOWN TO 14.
Jay: SOMEONE LIKE CASSIE--
SHE REALLY TURNED IT OUT HERE,
BUT IN HER INTERVIEW,
SHE MADE ME NERVOUS
BECAUSE OF HER WHOLE BACKGROUND
WITH THE STRIPPER.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO AMANDA.
HER EYES ARE, LIKE,
SPELLBINDING.
Jay: I LOVE WHAT
JULIE REPRESENTS.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
AN INDIAN MODEL.
J.: FLAG GIRL.
MY COUNTRY 'TIS OF THEE.
THE CHALLENGE FOR ME WILL BE
GIVING HER A NECK.
ANYWAY, NORELLE--I THINK
NORELLE HAS REALLY BIG,
BEAUTIFUL PUPPY DOG EYES.
Jay: WHAT ABOUT THE BRACES?
Tyra: YOU CAN'T BOOK JOBS
WITH BRACES, BUT YOU CAN BE
TRAINED WITH BRACES.
Tyra: BUT HER BRACES ARE
ABOUT TO COME OFF.
Jay: ANN?
Tyra: IN THIS PICTURE,
I SEE, LIKE, BEAT YOU UP.
J.: MAGDALENA, I THINK,
SHOULD BE GREAT TO DO
THESE HAIR CAMPAIGNS.
Tyra: YAYA.
I LIKED HER AFROCENTRIC VIBE.
Jay: HER SKIN, THOUGH,
MIGHT BE AN ISSUE.
Tyra: NARGIS HAS SUCH
A GOOD, LIKE, "HEY, WHAT'S UP?"
KIND OF QUALITY.
I JUST WISH SHE WANTED
TO MODEL MORE.
Jay: EVA--
WHEN SHE FIRST WALKED IN
TO MEET US, DIDN'T SHE JUST
WALK IN AND SERVE IT?
J.: YES, SHE DID.
Tyra: 'CAUSE SHE DOES HAVE
A BIG EGO.
Jay: BUT LOOK HOW INSECURE
SHE IS IN HERE.
TOCCARA AND MARY?
J.: I LIKE MARY.
Jay: I THINK MARY
IS MORE BEAUTIFUL,
AND HER BODY IS INCREDIBLE.
PROPORTION IS GREAT.
Tyra: TOCCARA--
I LIKED HER PERSONALITY,
BUT I AGREE WITH YOU.
SHE REALLY ISN'T PROPORTIONAL
AT ALL.
J.: BUT I WOULD TAKE
HER PERSONALITY OVER HER BODY.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
WE GOT 20 GIRLS.
I WANNA KNOW WHICH SIX
OF THESE GIRLS YOU THINK
SHOULD BE SENT HOME.
Leah: ALREADY WE ARE HAVING
ANOTHER ELIMINATION.
THERE'S 20 GIRLS THAT ARE JUST
LOOKING AND WONDERING
AND THINKING, AND LIKE,
EVERYTHING'S ON THE LINE.
SO IT'S FREAKING ME OUT.
LIKE, I JUST WANNA KNOW.
Toccara: MM!
I'M JUST MAKING MY PICKS.
I GOT SOME PEOPLE
THAT'S GONNA BE ELIMINATED.
(laughter)
Yaya: I WANT THIS AS THOUGH
IT WERE SOMETHING THAT
WAS PLANNED OUT FOR ME ALREADY.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT THIS.
Toccara: WE THE BOOTY GIRLS.
Mary: THERE'S TWO
PLUS-SIZE GIRLS, SO HOPEFULLY
THEY PICK BOTH OF US,
AND WE HAVE NOTHING
TO WORRY ABOUT.
(applause)
Tyra: HELLO.
I WANNA CONGRATULATE YOU GUYS
FOR GETTING THIS FAR.
I HAVE 14 NAMES
ON THIS LIST IN FRONT OF ME,
AND THESE 14 NAMES REPRESENT
THE 14 OF YOU THAT WILL
CONTINUE ON THIS JOURNEY
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BUT FOR SIX OF YOU,
THIS WILL BE THE END.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
ANN.
Eva: (gasps)
Tyra: THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
LEAH.
YOU'RE IN SHOCK?
(chuckles)
KELLE.
CASSIE.
CAN I GET A YAYA?
Yaya: (squeals)
(sighs)
Tyra: KRISTI.
JULIE.
MAGDALENA.
THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL--
NICOLE.
AMANDA.
I HAVE FOUR NAMES LEFT.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Norelle: OH, MY GOD!
(sniffles)
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Toccara: OHH!
Tyra: I HAVE TWO NAMES LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL--
JENNIPHER.
Jennipher: THANK YOU.
Tyra: I HAVE ONE NAME LEFT.
THIS ONE GIRL WILL BE THE LAST
OF THE 14.
THE LAST NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
EVA.
Woman: YEAH!
Women: (chattering)
Woman: YOU CALLED ME UGLY!
ALL MY HATERS!
OVER EVERYONE!
Nargis: IT'S MY SECOND TIME,
AND I GOT PLAYED OUT
FOR THE SECOND TIME,
SO I'M KINDA HURT.
I KINDA THOUGHT
I WAS GONNA GET IT.
Tyra: RACHAEL, IT'S TYRA.
HEY.
Rachael: OH, MY GOD.
Tyra: COME HERE.
Mary: BEING A PART
OF SOMETHING THAT I LOVE SO MUCH
SINCE I WAS A LITTLE KID--
I JUST THOUGHT THAT GOD
WAS LIKE, "OKAY, WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU A BREAK."
LIKE, "WE'RE JUST GONNA MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN FOR YOU."
Tyra: GIVE ME A HUG.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY SAY
IF IT AIN'T BROKE, DON'T FIX IT?
Rachael: YEAH.
Tyra: BUT THIS AIN'T
WORKIN', RIGHT?
SO WE NEED TO FIX IT
AND TRY SOMETHIN' ELSE.
Rachael: I HAVEN'T FOUND
ANYTHING THAT DOES WORK.
Tyra: YOU SHOULD TRY RED.
MAYBE THIS MIGHT WORK,
THIS AIN'T NATURAL.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
Eva: I TOLD YOU!
(laughter)
Toccara: IT'S ON NOW.
IT'S ON. I'M BIG AND BEAUTIFUL.
AND IT'S NO OTHER
PLUS-SIZE GIRL, SO I HAVE TO
GO IN THERE AND WORK IT.
Amanda: SO IT'S
GONNA BE HARD, ESPECIALLY, LIKE,
ME HAVING THE DISABILITY,
BUT YOU CAN DO ANYTHING YOU WANT
IF YOU WORK THROUGH IT.
Eva: THIS IS DEFINITELY
A SECOND CHANCE,
AND I'M GONNA MAKE
EVERYBODY PROUD
AND TRY TO TAKE IT ALL.
(shouting)
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
THE FINAL 14 FLY TO NEW YORK.
Jennipher: WHOO!
Ann: I WANT YOU TO WIN THIS
MORE THAN I WANT ME TO WIN THIS.
Tyra: SOME GIRLS
GROW CLOSER...
Ann: I LOVE YOU.
Tyra: SOME DON'T FIT IN.
Kelle: PEOPLE ASK ME,
WHAT PAIR OF PANTS
ARE YOU WEARING?
THEY'RE GUCCI,
I CAN'T HELP THAT.
Tyra: AND A SURPRISE
PHOTO SHOOT PUTS THEM ALL
TO THE TEST.
Jay: ONE OF YOU,
AT THE END OF THIS PHOTO SHOOT,
WILL BE GOING HOME.
♪♪♪